this is a great story did this star of
ted lasso treat his ex like an a-ho
what i don't know can you say that i
just did harris hey mind your own
beeswax
or was it a process server with a lot of
nerve er
olivia wilde was served custody papers
by her ex jason sudekis siddiques
whatever while she was on stage at
cinemacon
not to be confused with cinemacron a
festival of erotic films starring the
french president
but apparently at this forum security
allows people to approach celebrities
despite will smith still being on the
loose
wild was handed a manila envelope
possibly from the philippines
read it and then calmly went to the
trailer of her new movie don't worry
darling well you got something to worry
about now toots but at least it got some
publicity for the flick a source told
page six that sudicus sudeikis whatever
had no idea that the papers would be
delivered at the time saying he would
never condone her being served in such
an inappropriate manner which was
followed by a second statement wink wink
meanwhile sources for wild said i would
like to remind you all that olivia is
now dating harry styles
which means she could potentially change
her last name to wild styles which is
also what they called me in high school
wild styles
jamie you're an expert in this
has this ever happened to you
let's get paper served while you're on
stage doing like comedy
no the this story is insane like yes it
is how did this possibly have i remember
once being on stage someone gave me a
piece of paper said something like
please stop i don't even know what that
means
um
must have been for somebody else
but
the whole thing feels like a publicity
thing because it's so crazy yeah and
jason i mean i know him but you know i
mean by that i mean i've seen this show
and he seems like such a nice guy so i
don't think he would do that look at
olivia well
she's uh she's gorgeous by the way i
would not kick her out of bed for eating
crackers even if crackers was the name
of my cat
oh my gosh i want to get up
you got about two more segments harris
bear with us you know
paris
are you going to tell me to mind my own
beast i thought she handled it
remarkably well yeah there was no change
in her facial expressions she just i
mean that's a true pro used to getting
divorced
all right you know what i don't like the
fact that they could just walk up to
stage again after what happened with
with chris rock well i don't care i
don't like it no my thing is it's such
an antiquated process
process serving it's like they're at
we're in the tech age i mean the idea
that like somebody has to walk up to and
give it to you yeah but i guess you have
to have a receipt right or you have to
take a picture of her getting the text
like i don't know it just seemed like a
bad idea to have people accessing people
on stage but i mean seriously you will
never convince me that siddiques didn't
know that that was going to happen yeah
i know that this is the thing about like
uh who do i go to on this one
cat
like no matter what goes on in a
relationship legal that when the legal
stuff gets involved it's never good it's
like it's like they didn't have to do
that but they did it anyway what are
your thoughts on this very sensitive
matter
i mean like i think she's going to be
okay yeah
dating harry styles dating harry styles
like i hope that one day
my ex can serve me papers
for our child while i'm like like from
like talking about my movie like on a
stage that's amazing you would have
happily most people are just like at
applebee's and they find you yeah no
like
not that there's anything wrong with
applebee's i love applebee's they're
after to die for well some have normally
imagine like it's a really
it's a i think this is the best way it
could have happened yes it's probably
like a tough thing but then you get all
that attention but what about otis and
zayn she gets you go cry like oh harry
styles i'm so upset about what happened
harry styles and then he gets
wow you did that well but what are you
noticing these are like these are not i
can't feel bad for people who who have
these problems but they're children
involved there are but they're children
with very rich parents yeah
i literally just went through this and
when i saw this it was sad to me your
wife didn't know he was not an apple
like divorce and children in custody and
the first thing i thought was like how
do you guys not settle this at a coffee
shop or something without lawyers it's
just i don't know it was like sad so you
should be able to do it electronically
because you can put a thing on your
gmail but you can tell if the other
person opens your email or not oh really
not that i've ever done that's not how
the law works as the lawyer here i'm
going to play the notice process serving
yes it is very antiquated but yeah this
is this is comedy let me tell you
but there are very very specific
requirements for notice and they are not
going to change because of the tech era
these are things that have been in place
since like common law began in the 1800s
right it's real serious it's not
changing anytime soon and let me tell
you jamie that's comedy you split that
number out that's that's good stuff you
spit that number out like a president
biden
eighteen zero one two three four five
[Laughter]
well it's interesting i hope i never get
served
well
oh my goodness where are we going here
are these celebs unique or are they
blood sucking freaks
yeah
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else